imagine you're on the muddy trenches on
the western front during world war one
you're wet and shivering and can't get
warm
your days are marked by sleeplessness
fear and cigarettes that are too soggy
to light
death is all around you
on the other side across from no man's
land are enemies soldiers with
advancements in technology your comrades
are mowed down by machine guns in
numbers beyond
imagination but you have no time to
mourn just fight lest you suffer the
same fate
but then amid unrelenting violence the
bloodshed and brutality suddenly
stop you put your weapons down cross the
enemy lines shake hands and pose for
photos with your foe even play a game of
soccer or football
to this day it remains one of the
strangest moments in the history of war
on christmas eve 1914 captain arthur
sullivan of the british army's royal
irish rifles was stationed in france on
the northern border with belgium the
guns were silent and he heard a german
voice say do not shoot after 12 o'clock
and we will not do so either
if you english come out and talk to us
we won't fire was it a trick there was
only one way to know for sure
an irishman dared to venture out to no
man's land the area between the opposing
army's trenches and was not shot at when
he reached the german side an enemy
soldier gave him a cigarette when he
returned safely his comrades clambered
out of the trench and went to meet the
germans halfway across no man's land
their superiors would be forgiven for
reacting with more caution brigade
headquarters cabled back warning it is
thought possible that enemy may be
contemplating an attack during christmas
or new year special vigilance will be
maintained during this period
at 8 30 pm that night captain
o'sullivan's commanding officer colonel
george laurie reported to headquarters
germans have illuminated their trenches
are singing songs and wishing us happy
christmas
compliments are being exchanged but i'm
nevertheless taking all military
precautions colonel laurie described the
germans as fine men clean and well
clothed
they gave us a cap and helmet badge and
a box of cigars
one of them states that the war would be
over in three weeks as they defeated
russia
despite thinking the war would be over
soon world war one would actually last
four years leaving 10 million soldiers
dead and about as many civilians
yet for a fleeting moment good appeared
to triumph over evil
instead of exchanging bullets sworn
enemies exchanged handshakes colonel
laurie later recalled you have no idea
how pleasant everything seems with no
rifle bullets or shells flying about
further down the line a german officer
who was a tenor in the berlin opera
began singing silent night in both
german and english encouraging his
comrades whose voices flowed over to the
british trenches
the contrast between the christmas
carol's message of peace and the
violence of war was striking
the same spirit of camaraderie sprung up
in various sectors along the front which
weaved more than 400 miles through
france and belgium
soldiers later wrote to their loved ones
expressing their disbelief over what had
occurred british soldier private
frederick heath described in his letter
home that he heard the germans say come
out english soldier come out here to us
for some little time we were cautious
and did not even answer
officers fearing treachery ordered the
men to be silent
but up and down our line one heared the
men answering that christmas greeting
from the enemy
how could we resist wishing each other a
merry christmas
even though we might get each other's
throats immediately afterwards
so we kept up a running conversation
with the germans all the while our hands
ready on our rifles
blood and peace enmity and fraternity
wars most amazing paradox
the night wore on to a dawn a night made
easier by songs from the german trenches
the pipings of piccolo's and from our
broad lines laughter and christmas
carols
not a shot was fired
the front page of the illustrated london
news showed a german soldier approaching
the british lines with a small tree as a
sign of a truce
very cautiously allied and german
soldiers climbed out of their trenches
and crossed no man's land where they
shared drinks with their enemies as
depicted in the film joao noel i don't
think anyone would criticize us for
laying down our rifles on christmas eve
don't worry it is just for tonight
the guns remain silent on christmas day
although there were accounts of fighting
in some sectors the imperial war museums
believes the truce extended along at
least two-thirds of the british held
trench line in southern belgium
german and british soldiers can be seen
standing together in photographs taken
on personal cameras that the soldiers
brought into the trenches with them it
was not easy for them to communicate
however what they did have in common was
an interest in sports a british private
described at least a couple hundred
soldiers kicking around a football this
was one of several impromptu soccer
matches played in no man's land
amongst the joy there was sadness as
both sides also used this opportunity to
recover the bodies of their fallen
comrades and give them a decent burial
which they couldn't do in the heat of
battle
headlines around the world spread the
news of the christmas truce which must
have seemed incredulous to the public
especially since british government
propaganda portrayed german soldiers as
ruthless barbaric monsters and yet the
british were seen mingling with the
enemy
a german lieutenant recalled
how marvelously wonderful
yet how strange it was
the english officers felt the same way
about it
thus christmas the celebration of love
managed to bring mortal enemies together
as friends for a time
for a time is right because the
following day they went back to shooting
each other
strict orders came down from the pike
and they had to retreat back to their
trenches this would be the only
widespread christmas truce during the
course of the entire four-year war high
commands on both sides prohibited
fraternizing with the enemy and the war
became increasingly bitter after the
introduction of poison gas the following
year and the number of casualties began
to pile up
the christmas truce of 1914 was such an
anomaly so hard to believe that over
time some people doubted that it even
happened despite all the evidence to the
contrary british machine gunner bruce
baron's father who later became a
prominent cartoonist depicted the truce
in his work in this cartoon he shows
himself taking a fancy to the buttons of
the german officer they agreed to do a
swap
in his memoirs baron's father described
the incredulity of it all
here they were
the actual practical soldiers of the
german army
there was not an atom of hate on either
side
even in the darkest hour good triumphed
over evil if just for a day
they had gotten to know the enemy and
realized they were more alike than they
thought
making these videos takes up a lot of my
time so i like to make sure the rest of
my day is as hassle free as possible and
that's down to the wallet that i use
so this is the wallet that i used to use
and this is the wallet that i currently
own an extra wallet it's clearly a lot
more sleek and simpler i actually
started using an extra wallet before the
company approached me to see if i was
interested in getting them to sponsor
some of my videos and i said of course
yes i absolutely love extra wallets
they're super simple to use all you have
to do is press this button
and then you can access to all your
cards i especially love this model in
particular because there's a spot to put
my air tag which is very convenient
because i don't have to spend time
looking for my wallet in the house i
know where it is at all times there are
so many models to choose from you can
check them out on their website exter
also sent me this really cool wallet
this is made of carbon fiber it's super
sleek and very minimalistic and i
absolutely love the design to go along
with it you can also get yourself a
smart tracking card exters runs on solar
power all it needs is three hours in the
sun and it lasts two months
if you'd like to try out an extra wallet
you can get twenty percent off if you
head to the custom link in my
description that's
shop.exter.com
newsthink
shop.extra.com
newsthink for 20 off thanks so much for
watching for news think i'm cindy palm